[Music]
catherine's in london hi catherine
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi ken thank you very much for
taking my call and this is my first time
calling in so i'm thrilled to have got
through well we're honored to have you
how can we help
um okay so my question
um
so essentially i'm in a job that i don't
love
um
but i have the equivalent of about
twenty thousand twenty seven thousand
dollars worth of debt
that i need to pay off my job is well
paid um
i make about
98 000
equivalent um
before tax um then i
i i want out and but then i i've got
this debt that i need to pay i have an
eight-year-old son
he's in private school um that i'm
paying for um
and
my question essentially is
how do i plan
and exit from a job that i don't love
yeah well do you like it
okay well couple things don't walk into
this with the assumption that if you
change jobs that you have to take a big
pay cut and we're not going to jump off
of a cliff here we don't want to see any
interruption in income so catherine if
there's no interruption in income and
you can step into something else that is
much more enjoyable
that doesn't have all the factors at
play that's going on with what's going
on now you wouldn't even be calling us
you'd be like okay and so let's let's
start with the assumption that we're not
going to have an interruption in income
okay that's first but the question is do
you know what you would love to do or is
there a job that you are very intrigued
by a career path that you've always
wanted to pursue
to be honest i'm not sure i'm i'm 45 um
and i kind of feel like that's so i work
in healthcare and i've worked in
healthcare for 25 years okay um
and i have been looking at other roles
that are within my field but i quite and
you know
it's um
it's quite a thriving industry at the
moment but every role that i come across
i just i don't even bother to read the
whole
job spec but i'm just not interested and
i just i don't know if it's because you
know if it's a combination of
um
part of the reason why i don't love my
job okay all right so let me know
or the pandemic i kind of feel like i
don't want to do this anymore yeah well
you have to listen to that but here's
what i want you to do
you've got some debt you make really
good money and you've got some debt that
you can pay off
pretty quickly if you stay focused so
for right now catherine i want you to
stay in this job i know you don't love
it i know you want out but let's change
our attitude the attitude is hey i'm
grateful for this job because it's
taking care of me my eight-year-old son
and it's allowing me to pay off debt and
i'm going to stay put until i've got
something to step into
so that's our focus so here's what i
want to do kelly let's give catherine a
link to the get clear career assessment
that we sell here ramsey solutions
kencoleman.com would you take the
assessment it's going to point out a
whole lot to you that you've never seen
before and then let's come up with a
clear path hang on we're going to give
you the brand new from paycheck to
purpose because it's the field guide to
the mountain that the assessment will
point out both of these tools catherine
will show you the direction that you
need to go walk through it stage by
stage don't interrupt your income and
you're going to be fine